now
p
refers to the probability function
uppercase p with parentheses refers to the probability function.
Let's quickly jump to the previous example, where
we where we're talking about there. Probably Mass function.
And let me quickly, correct this equal sign that equal sign shouldn't
be there. It's confusing.
So we want to go into.
Probability normal distribution, let me get rid of that equal
sign.
Yeah much better. So whenever you see this whenever she
uppercase p with parentheses.
That's the probability function.
Okay. So let's first look at the previous example,
so we can understand why we have this situation.
Why we have an inequality.
as the argument
for they probably Mass function.
So let's jump to
the example for the pmf
probability Mass function
I'm just going to jump to the answer just to remind you.
Hopefully you've all watched the video or you attended the
session before so you don't have to we don't have to go through these examples again,
but when you when you type in
P what parentheses and then you pass to it some argument.
You're saying what is the probability?
Mass function of that particular situation
Here we're saying what is the probability of x?
taking on the value 0
Okay. Another one is here we have what
is the probability that X will take on the value 1?
And then what you would do.
Is you would calculate the probabilities corresponding
to that X. So for example up here?
One X equals to 1
Yeah, so for example.
This this example was about six boxes.
Six boxes containing some mechanical
parts and some of those boxes
had defects. So for example box number one
has zero defects box. Number two had two defects box.
Number three had zero defects also but walks number
four this particular box one defect there were
some mechanical parts of that box one of the most effective. So this here
when we look at the probability Mass function we asking what is
the probability
That one of those boxes would be defective.
Okay.
And we do the probability if you remember the basic probability that comes
up to 0.67.
Okay, that's what they probably Mass function is.
Now there's another one that uses the same
notation that uses the same letter P. This is important call the
cumulative distribution function.
cumulative distribution function
except with the
Cumulative distribution of function we don't use just
we don't use the equal sign we use the inequality.
So less than or equal or greater than or equal.
So for example, here's another example these correspond the
the Y's.
the Y's here
are the
the experiments
within the random variable y uppercase Y
is the random variable small Y is the experiment.
So, for example, we have one experiment.
where this was about flash drives, by the way one experiment
you have
This is a the first experiment is when
the when the flash drive is one GB. The second
experiment was is when the flash drive is 2GB. The third
experiment is when the flash drive
is 4GB and so on. Okay the probability
that
The first experiment will happen that is
to say the first a flash drive of
1GB will be sold is 5% the probability that for
example an HGB flash
drive will be sold is 40% Okay, the cumulative
distribution function wants to know
or asks.
What is the probability as you add them up? So for
example here we have we're asking.
What is the probability that random variable
will be less than or equal to 4?
that is to say
experiment experiment one experiment experiment one
or experiment to or experimentary or experiment
4 will happen.
Okay, this is one experiment another experiment third experiment for
experiment we're asking what is the probability the cumulative
probability that these four experiments? What
happened?
Well, if you want to know the probability that all four of these experiments will
happen you simply add up their corresponding probability. You add
0.5.
Plus 0.1.35 plus
4 you add up those probabilities and you get the
cumulative distribution or excuse me, the cumulative
probability 4.
all of these for experiments